hey everyone it's Michael Volos from
orderflows decom and I'm going give you
a preview of my webinar tomorrow that
I'm doing uh with investor inspiration
I'll be speaking at uh 12:15 eastern
time and I'll be talking about how to
get an edge in the market with orderflow
analysis now you know I'm an orderflows
guy and what you see on the chart here
is a is a bar chart actually
and this is the NASDAQ this morning it
was not very clear in here that if you
should be selling at this swing high or
not um let me just get the actual chart
up here and just sort of break it down
for you again I'll I'll be talking about
this uh this particular move yes um
tomorrow this was a move today this is
Thursday morning this is NASDAQ this a
eight range chart
and you can see okay so let me just
whoops that's not the move um where was
it here 854 this one here okay sorry and
you know Candlestick people say oh you
know you got this particular type of
Candlestick uh this dark cloud cover
where starts coming back in here like
this okay well you have that here you
have it um here you know this Market
didn't sell off you have it here the
market didn't sell off you know other uh
traditional
uh technical analysts will say oh you
got head and shoulders right here
there's your head here's your shoulder
shoulder your neckline here well that's
all well and good but you know you're
getting short you know way down here how
would you like getting short right up
here you know and with order flow L is
very clear even if you're trading The
Head and
Shoulders you know you're you're getting
short here then it starts rallying back
up here you don't know if it's going to
go higher or
not but you know again you know that's
where orderflow comes in you know you're
going to be getting a better trade entry
than you know if you're using
traditional technical analysis you know
again you know there your head here's
your uh left shoulder here's your right
shoulder here's your neckline you break
your neckline you know you get the
little bit of a move down but then you
start coming back up before you get the
big move down you know where would you
rather be short somewhere in here or
somewhere you know up here around the
5606 level rather than the 56 5598 area
you know what would you rather risk on
the trade this little bar right here
this little move or as opposed to you
know trading a a head and shoulders
formation where's your risk you know
your risk is is way up here you know you
you're risking a lot more with
traditional technical analysis than you
are with order flow so you know I'm
going to talk about
that trade setup um how you could have
picked it up with the order flow you
know it's not like order flow is going
to give you every every single high and
low but there's going to be times where
things just really stand out in the
order flow that you know you'll you'll
kick yourself if you didn't take that
trade so again you know register for my
webinar tomorrow go to orderflows
docomo uh register. HTML um it'll take
you to a signup page that's me here um
you I'll be talking about a bunch of
stuff you know why Traders fail and how
orderflow will save you how to profit
from Clear orderflow developments in the
market as they occur
and a simple orderflow trade setup that
finds Market turning points with very
low risk and that is this
particular um example uh this is you
know I was I was just going through my
slide deck for the presentation tomorrow
um and you know this
this trade setup happened today and it
happens every day it happens several
times in certain markets like NASDAQ you
know this is a particular trade setup in
the NASDAQ that I really look for in the
NASDAQ and you know there's a few
markets that trade like NASDAQ Dax as
well um but you know it also appeared in
the S&P this morning also appeared in
the bonds this morning so you know it
it's it's a great trade setup you know
so it's worth going onto the webinar
just to uh just to hear me talk about it
so again you know just register for my
webinar it's uh orderflows
docomo to the link it's in the
description it's free if you can't
attend that's fine just register then
you'll get access to the replay so you
can watch it um you know over the
weekend when you're free and if you
don't learn something from me hopefully
you can learn from something from you
know some of the other presenters
there's a total of seven of us so sign
up and I I look forward to seeing you on
the presentation tomorrow thanks bye-bye